[Música]
hablamos precisamente del conflicto en
yemen y cómo afecta a la región en los
últimos días los útiles lanzaron misiles
hacia los emiratos árabes unidos arabia
saudita lo que aumentó las tensiones en
represalia la coalición árabe liderada
por riad respondió con ataques aéreos es
una guerra devastadora especialmente
para la población yemení una de las más
pobres del mundo el petróleo y las rutas
comerciales son la clave de una guerra
que está matando de hambre al pueblo de
yemen y deja miles de desplazados como
afecta este conflicto a oriente medio lo
hablamos con nuestra primera invitada
del día ya susana mangana directora de
la cátedra permanente el islam en la
universidad católica de uruguay
investigadora doctoral de la universidad
de deusto en derechos humanos y también
analista internacional gracias susana
por estar con nosotros en directo
américa de francés 24 muy buen día por
favor vamos a dar entonces un contexto a
nuestra audiencia a un contexto general
de cómo comenzó esta guerra y quiénes
son los protagonistas principales de
este conflicto
muy buenos días raúl efectivamente es un
conflicto de los que llamamos olvidados
y un conflicto enquistado el de yemen es
un país muy pobre en la península
árabiga vecino de países grandes
poderosos y sobre todo muy ricos como es
el reino de arabia saudita pero hace
siete años que la población civil viene
sufriendo una guerra civil pero también
los embates de los ataques y una
coalición de fuerzas árabes lideradas
sobre todo por emiratos árabes unidos- y
por el propio reino de arabia saudi
quiénes son los que están peleando esta
guerra tan desigual tan asimétrica pues
son sobre todo el bando de los hutíes
son leales a un señor de la guerra
yemení que lucha contra la ocupación y
la injerencia extranjera de arabia
saudita que a su vez argumenta que tiene
razones de peso para seguir
interviniendo en el conflicto de siemens
porque a quien está combatiendo
realmente es a su rival en la región del
golfo pérsico que es la república
islámica de irán hace siete años
entonces que la población yemení viene
sufriendo
cólera hambruna pero también la falta de
agua potable de alimentos de medicina
porque aunque se intenta enviar ayuda
desde el extranjero al calor de lo que
han sido las primaveras árabes hace ya
más de una década que se iniciaron esas
revueltas hay razones geopolíticas y
geoestratégicas para que occidente haya
mirado a un costado y haya dejado hacer
de las suyas al reino de arabia saudita
que está librando esta guerra contra la
república islámica de irán en el
territorio de terceros es decir en yemen
raúl ahora a susana porque este
conflicto entonces es tan importante en
esta geopolítica de oriente medio
porque creando que se está peleando aquí
es por la supremacía regional es decir
emiratos árabes unidos- y también la
monarquía saudí lo que quieren es evitar
que haya una mayor injerencia de iranzu
su rival en el golfo pérsico como digo
porque ya ha extendido sus tentáculos en
la región tanto con su intervención en
siria como también aupando y apoyando a
otros próximos como puede ser el grupo
paramilitar de hit bullard el líbano y
por tanto lo canarias sabe y quiere
frenar es el avance de esta injerencia y
el avance de la expansión iraní en un
territorio que para ellos es vital como
este el sur de la península árabiga
ahora quiénes son estos rebeldes útiles
en teoría y también en la práctica y que
tienen que ver con irá porque ira nos
apoya tanto
bueno los hutíes son seguidores de como
dije antes un señor de la guerra que
responda el nombre de al jurf y de ahí
viene el término judío si es verdad pero
en realidad no son todos familiares de
este señor sino que pertenecen al clan
de los hutíes y practican el islam en su
vertiente chií por tanto una afinidad
ideológica pero sobre todo se necesitan
mutuamente irán necesita próximos en el
terreno para que hagan su trabajo sucio
por así decirlo pero a su vez estas
personas necesitan de la financiación
del adiestramiento que brinda
generosamente irán porque le interesa
seguir conquistando territorios almas
pero sobre todo para hacer mella en sus
adversarios como es la monarquía saudí
recordemos que en siria se ha librado
una cruenta guerra civil todavía no se
ha decretado el final de la misma el
infierno en siria continúa pero allí han
intervenido todas las potencias
regionales desde turquía irán o arabia
saudí como también otras de la ex para
región que llamamos como pueden ser
estados unidos reino unido o rusia
también hay algo llama la atención de
susana y es porque esta coalición
liderada por arabia saudita uno de los
países más armados del mundo no termina
de ganar esta guerra oa lo mejor no se
decide a dar su punto final su remate
no realmente intenta ganar la guerra lo
que ocurre es que no han tenido una
buena estrategia se han limitado a
atacar a dejar caer misiles a matar la
población civil amedrentarlos a sembrar
el terror pero realmente arabia saudi
carece de la experiencia del terreno
como si la tienen los milicianos no sólo
los cutié sino los combatientes porque
es un terreno que orográficamente es muy
difícil de conquistar como ocurre
también con afganistán ahora bien yo
creo que la falta de experiencia militar
de arabia saudí- es realmente lo que ha
determinado que esta guerra duró ya
siete años algo que no sospechaba el
príncipe heredero mohammad bin salman
cuando como ministro de defensa lanzó
este ataque indiscriminado contra
población que sufre mucho como es la
población yemení y por eso te agradezco
raúl por estos minutos en los que
hablamos de un conflicto que por lo
general suele estar perdido en las
páginas internacionales y nos hemos
olvidado de la miseria humana que está
ocurriendo allí y es una catástrofe
realmente muy importante porque la
padecen los más pobres de la tierra ya
por último susana tenemos solamente un
minuto hay un término algunos expertos
han acuñado en los últimos años la
guerra fría alguien te me dio a qué se
refieren con esto
bueno pues se refiere justamente a esta
guerra latente que hay entre dos
adversarios que están luchando por la
hegemonía regional como son la república
islámica dirán que si tiene experiencia
militar ha librado una guerra de ocho
años contra el vecino irak también del
80 al 88 y el reino de arabia saudi que
quiere capitanear al bloque suní
enfrentándose así al bloque que lidera
iran que son los chiíes y por eso se
habla de una guerra fría latente entre
los dos adversarios que justamente se
están disputando la hegemonía del mundo
musulmán pero sobre todo el control de
la hegemonía regional en la zona del
golfo persa